morning today is world obesity day here
in the u.s unfortunately more than 30
percent of adults are obese alex
yeah bianca holman is live with how
advocates are raising awareness about
this health issue and how we can all get
healthy good morning bianca
[Applause]
hey good morning alex good morning john
you know this day is all about
raising awareness and talking about
habits that we can start doing today to
lead to a healthier lifestyle and i'm
joined by jay joseph who
once was obese himself after getting out
of the military so
what can people do who are able-bodied
and mobile what can we do to support
our loved ones that may be struggling
with their weight obese or have mobility
issues
a positive energy we can assist them in
their own goals we can
come up with new ideas we can assist
with ideas to change
our um that will change their eating
habits
or just overall don't invite them to
things that aren't going to be
beneficial to their habits
you know you have to be that positive
echo in their lifestyle as well
you can't be somebody that's a liability
every time they come around them that's
going to put them back on the path they
don't want to be on yeah so support is
definitely necessary it takes a whole
community kind of implementing these
these strategies and so something that
we can do at home right now
everybody you know this is a box but if
you have a chair what can you do with it
all right so what you can do with this
right now is i'm gonna show you guys how
to box squat all right you can do these
over intervals or you can do these
through reps
intervals time simply chest up sit down
keep your heels rooted through the
ground all right you can speed up
you can slow down if you want to get
fancy if you have weights at home
you can add water you can add things
around the home that way yourself
but this is something that's simple that
we can do all right anything
you said the key is also kind of keeping
your knee above your
uh above your ankle right kind of
keeping a 90 degree angle yes
absolutely while you're working you want
to maintain proper form so you want to
have your heels in the ground
90 degree angle as you sit you want to
have your heel beneath your kneecap you
don't want to have any more than that
all right chest up push up lower
yourself down
push up lower yourself down so all of
that i mean like you said with the chair
you can start moving your body right
immediately and this is something again
you can do right now at home if you
don't have to get out and put on the
spare sneakers and go to the gym or go
out and do a walk maybe again
starting right now in a chair that
you're in is something that everybody
could probably do right now
thank you so much we're going to show
something else we got something else
coming up for you
in the next half hour some more tips
that we can do to help encourage
a positive and healthy lifestyle back to
you guys in the studio
just take your chair alex that's all we
need is the chairs of some water you
stand up you sit down you're good to go
if only it was that easy all right thank
you so much bianca we'll see you just a
little bit